we plan to put a lot of other Janet
Corps equipment so as you could imagine
Janet supports research and education a
lot of students are using the network
not only for their their studies but
they live in halls of residence so we
move a lot of Netflix traffic around the
network so we'll be putting some Netflix
caches that help to manage that that
traffic more efficiently on the network
we have direct pairings with Google and
Amazon to manage their traffic directly
onto the network
it is yes yeah that will go across Janet
directly into the Amazon Network
we've got terabytes essentially of spare
capacity in the current systems this is
where the Janet Network enters the data
center the data center is actually on
the core of the Janet Network so we have
diverse fibre going out to two of our
core points of presence one in East
London in Docklands and one in West
London and that's how it connects to the
the Janet network so we have our optical
equipment lighting that fiber which is
the owner optical equipment so at the
moment we've got two 200 gig wavelengths
and we're about to add a second set of
100 gig wavelengths as well and then we
have the Juniper routing equipment
universities but it's not not that
exciting it's basically a a pair of
fibers coming in in one side of the
building and then another pair of fibers
coming in into the other side of the
building and as I say those fibers go to
a location in East London and a location
in in West London that's right they go
into the optical equipment and then into
the the IP switching equipment and we
either present one gig connections or
ten gig connections to each of the
customers the two fibers coming they
first of all coming to the the optical
equipment and that does be sort of demon
multiplexing out of the of the light
signal and then that gets put into the
switching and routing equipment to way
to each of the customers in the data
center connect so we have out of the
routing equipment individual pairs of
fiber that go into either data Hall one
or date of all to its fiber coming out
of the the equipment and that goes
through the the in data center patching
infrastructure so the sienar equipment
there
that on a single fiber is essentially
capable of carrying 8.8 terabytes of
information of the moment as we're
growing into the data center we've got
200 gigabytes soon to move up to 400
gigabytes this is the core equipment
that powers the earth the Janet network
so we have a national core that extends
from Exeter in the southwest up to
Edinburgh and Glasgow in Scotland we
have about six and a half thousand
kilometres of fiber that connects all
that core equipment and that core
connects to 17 regional distribution
networks that then connects to the
universities and the colleges and the
public research institutions so the
signals come in to the optical equipment
that's the owner equipment and then get
patched into the Juniper IP switching
and routing equipment in this rack here
this is taking me signal out of the
optical equipment converting that light
into the Internet Protocol signal and
then customers connect out on individual
ports so the signals come out of that
tuning that IP equipment
come in via the fibre patching into this
patching rack and then that'll go off
into the wiring infrastructure on this
yellow overhead trunking so we connect
two ways out into the date also it's
fully resilient so it'll it'll come out
into two of the overhead raceways and
then the diversity routed take different
routes into the date all of its going
into so if one of these overhead race
ways were to be damaged the other
Raceway would carry the signal no we
haven't no no not not in the data center
it's nearly again now it's been up and
running
well this is our first date to sent on
the network so this is the first time
we've done this yeah Janet is a very
high capacity very fast network and the
finger vein reader rather than just a
traditional fingerprint reader actually
searches for signs of life so as to make
sure that you haven't had your finger
cut off and summarize there is a very
important component in the grid which is
what we call the middleware let me
nervous